PROFESSOR: So that's
part of this story.
Let's try to understand
it a little better still.
So what does the
state look like?
Well the state looks like
e to the ikxx times a state
of the oscillator and y.
OK.
So what is happening here?
We could re-solve this problem
using a different gauge.
And you will.
You will solve it at
least once or twice.
Again, this problem
using a different gauge.
And the solutions are going to
be looking a little different
but, of course, you're going
to find the same Landau
levels and the same
infinite degeneracy.
The wave functions will
look sometimes a little
more intuitive.
So in this case,
one calculation that
is interesting to
try to understand
the physics of this degeneracy
is to work roughly a little
heuristically on a
finite size sample.
Imagine a material but
it's now finite size.
So let me remark to you what
are the degrees of freedom you
have here.
Suppose you solve this
Schrodinger equation
in a different gauge, a
symmetric gauge in which there
is an ay and an ax.
Solutions then are going
to look a little more
like circular orbits.
There's a little
more mathematics
involved in solving
it but they're
going to look a little nicer.
But how are they
related to this one?
Well anyone with
a circular orbit
must be related to this
solution by first forming
a superposition of
those solutions,
maybe localizing it or doing
something and then doing
a gauge transformation.
So in order to compare your
solutions in different gauges,
you have to dig into gun, you
have an infinite degeneracy,
and you have gauge
transformation.
So to see what state
here corresponds
to a particular
state here, it may
be the gauge transformation
of a particular superposition
in this side.
So it's, in general,
not all that easy to do.
OK.
So let's take a count
state in a finite sample.
So same picture, but now
the material is here.
And we'll put Lx and Ly here.
So finite size in the
Lx, finite size in Ly.
So given our intuition
with quantization,
this suggests that we impose
periodic boundary conditions
in x and try to
quantize the kx here.
In general, if you're
imposing thinking
of very large boxes,
which is the case here,
it doesn't matter
much whether you
impose periodic or vanishing
boundary conditions or anything
essentially at large number of
states it makes no difference.
So we quantize in x.
So we want e to the ikx
times x to be periodic
under x goes to x plus Lx.
I'm almost done with sine.
So kxLx will have to be
equal to a multiple with Nx.
Since we know that Y0 is
equal to minus kxlb squared,
we should take Nx negative so
that you're within the sample.
You must be in y
positive and therefore kx
should be negative,
Nx should be negative.
And now I have a way to count
because I can take Nx negative
up to some value minus Nx bar.
And when Nx grows,
kx grows and y grows.
So I can take the
last Nx that I can
use is the one in which the
orbit is still in the sample up
to the value Y0.
So this number is
really the degeneracy
because this is how many
values of Nx I can have,
from minus Nx up to 0,
are the number of values
that are consistent with a
state still in this sample.
So Y0 equal to Ly should
be equal to minus kx times
lb squared.
So it's minus 2 pi Nx bar
over Lx times lb squared.
And this gives you Nx.
We can solve for Nx there.
Nx is LyLx over lb
squared over 1 over 2 pi.
So Nx is the degeneracy.
This is the degeneracy.
And it's equal to the
area divided by lb
squared, which is h bar c
over qB times 1 over 2 pi.
So it's equal to area times b
divided by 2 pi h bar c over q.
So we're back to
the kind of thing
we were saying before in
which the degeneracy is
equal to the flux divided
by the flux quantum
that we figured
out earlier today.
So this is how much states
you can put on the sample.
So you're given a
magnetic field, a Tesla
and you have some area.
You find the fi,
you divide by fi0,
and that's the number
of degenerate states
of each Landau level.
So in particular, given that
we have that number that fi0
is equal to about 2 times
10 to the minus 7 Gauss then
centimeters squared.
If you have a sample
of 1 centimeter squared
and you put one Gauss, the
value of the flux over fi0
would be 1 Gauss centimeter
squared over 2 times 10
to the minus 7 same units.
So it's about 5 million states.
That's just to give you an idea
of how big the numbers are.
That's the degeneracy.
So this is a classic problem.
Very important in
condensed matter physics.
Is a first step in trying
to understand quantum Hall
effect on many things.
And it's important to solve it
and think it in several ways.
And I think you
will be doing that
in homework and recitation.